this episode of biographies is brought
to you
by magic spoon if you're a regular
viewer of my channel you might know that
i love me some cereal but cereal doesn't
always love me back
so many cereals are over processed and
have way too much sugar
as an adult i really used to eat cereal
because i just don't need that much
sugar in my life anyway along comes
magic spoon and they're like guess what
fact boy
this cereal has 14 grams of protein 4
grams of net carbs and only a 110
calories per serving and no
sugar what now i don't know much about
protein and carbohydrates and all that
stuff but i know that the former is good
for you and the latter probably not so
much
also zero sugar that pretty much sold me
it turns out magic spoon also tastes
amazing you'd think it's got no sugar
it's got loads of protein it's going to
taste weird and bad it doesn't it tastes
awesome this is the peanut butter flavor
that i'm having right now also on the
screen you'll see all of the other
flavors
they do there are a lot of them it's
also gmo free
low carb free all of that good stuff now
originally there were four flavors cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry
but just recently they've added new ones
peanut butter and cinnamon both of which
are actually my favorite i'd say the
peanut butter one tops it just a little
bit
it's incredible anyway click the link
below or go to magicspoon.com forward
slash biographics
try out a variety pack use the promo
code biographics you got five dollars
off magic spoon
100 happiness guarantee if you don't
like it you get your money back and
let's get into today's video
picture the scene you've just been
betrayed by one of your closest friends
somebody
you're almost considered family you
expected it from other people
but not from them as the realization
makes its way to your stunned mind
these three words almost automatically
come out of your mouth
you too brutus the phrase has become one
of the most famous quotes in english
literature purported to be the last
words of julius caesar when he
recognized his friend brutus
as one of his assassins it is now
uttered whenever someone wants to
express shock or dismay at somebody
else's betrayal
the line itself actually comes from a
shakespeare play julius caesar where it
is said
in its latin form of etu brute it is not
mentioned
in any ancient chronicle most roman
historians make no reference to caesar's
last words with the exception being
suetonius who
reports two phrases uttered by the
dictator during his assassination
according to him caesar initially cried
out why this is violence when somebody
first grabbed his toga and then when
brutus went to stab him he asked
incredulously you too
my child so this was probably
shakespeare's inspiration though
suetonius does specify that caesar said
it in greek not latin since
that was the language preferred by the
upper classes so it would have been
kai soo tekken instead of petu brute
and while we're being terribly
persnickety about the whole thing we
might as well mention that even in the
play this line is not caesar's last
words
afterwards he says then fall caesar and
dies
so as you can see there might be a few
problems if we try to take this phrase
as historical fact but we cannot deny
its long-lasting impact
this line alone turned brutus into one
of history's most notorious traitors
people who have no idea who he was or
what he did
still know his name and associate him
with betrayal
thanks to three little words that were
powerful enough to echo throughout
history
but now that we mention it who was
brutus what did he do those are the
questions we will answer today as we
take a look
at the man who betrayed julius caesar
and doomed the roman republic
marcus junius brutus was born circ 85 bc
the son of marcus junius brutus the
elder and
sevilla the half-sister of cato the
younger
his father was a tribune of the roman
republic but it was executed a few years
after his son's birth in 77 bc for
allying himself with men who started a
civil war strangely enough the execution
of brutus father was ordered by his
future ally
pompe the great after his father's death
young brutus was adopted by his uncle
quintus sivilius capo which prompted him
to change his name to quintus capio
brutus for a while before reverting back
to his birth name when he was young
brutus became an ardent follower of his
uncle cato who was a statesman renowned
for his oratorical skills and his
devotion to stoicism plutarch one of our
main sources for the life of brutus said
that he held no
other roman in higher esteem he also
became acquainted with all the greek
philosophers but showed a particular
interest
in plato ever since he was young brutus
was ingrained with the idea that his
family stood against tyranny
and those who posed a danger to the
roman republic that is because brutus
was born into one of the oldest most
respected families of rome
junior the junior traced their roots
back to lucius junius brutus a
semi-legendary figure who
helped to overthrow tarku in the proud
the last king of rome and then went on
to become one of the first consoles of
the roman republic
on his mother's side brutus was
descended from sevilla zahala a
politician considered a hero for
assassinating spurious malius a rich
plebeian who was allegedly planning a
coup
to bring down the republic and make
himself king as you can see the junior
family was hailed as a defender and
true believer of republican ideals so
it's not really surprising that these
same ideals stuck to brutus and
caused him to later take action against
julius caesar brutus's career started
around 58 bc when he served as an
assistant to his uncle he had been named
the new governor of cyprus he did this
for a few years before becoming quasar
for
the province of cilicia in 53 bc after a
few more years of this he returned to
rome a rich man and married his first
wife claudia about
whom we know very little he would later
divorce her and marry his cousin porsia
who was the daughter of cato the younger
by the time brutus had returned to rome
the republic was in turmoil up until
that point one of its most influential
groups was an informal alliance known as
the first triumvirate between
three of its most powerful politicians
julius caesar pompeii
and marcus desilius crassus even though
the three of them were not friends and
did not share political beliefs
they concluded that by working together
and helping each other
they each could earn more power and
wealth for themselves than they could on
their own
pompeii was the most respected military
commander of his time
caesar was the pontifex maximus the
chief
high priest and crisis was probably the
richest man in rome their alliance
worked well for years even though caesar
and pompei were never on the best of
terms with each other grasses was
always there to counteract their
animosity towards each other and pompe
even married caesar's daughter julia to
help solidify their alliance
things went south quickly in 54 bc when
julia died during childbirth thus
creating a major divide between pompei
and caesar just a few months later
marcus crassus also died fighting the
parthian empire
the first trombora was officially dead
and from now on it was every man for
himself and both caesar and pompeii
aspired to become the most powerful
force in rome but by the time brutus
arrived back in the city the gloves were
off
everyone expected him to side with
caesar pompeii did instigate the death
of his father after all
but that was not the case plutarch
credited brutus with putting the public
good above his own and
siding with pompei on the ground that
caesar was the greater threat to the
[Music]
republic
even though caesar had allied himself
with two powerful men he still had
plenty of enemies in rome
at the time there were two major
political factions in the republic the
populares
and the optimates the former was popular
with the plebeians aka the common people
and advocated for populist reforms while
the latter was conservative and
looked to preserve ancient roman laws
and the power of the senate
this was building up to more than just a
confrontation between
two men because caesar had the favor of
the populares while pompeii was
supported by the optimodes
before all of this while the first
triumvirate was still in effect with the
help of his allies
caesar had gained multiple governorships
and had
used the army at his command to conquer
ghoul this move was popular with the
people but it also provided ammunition
for his political enemies who
claimed that caesar did this without the
approval of the senate and that his
military campaign had been illegal
at the time caesar was safe because he
had been a pro-consul and this gave him
immunity from prosecution but that
expired in 50 bc while he hoped that his
friends in the senate would be able to
secure another consulship for him
this was not to be the case when his
biggest supporter mark antony tried to
push this motion he was expelled with
force from the senate with caesar's
immunity gone his adversaries in the
senate ordered him to disband his armies
and return to rome as a private citizen
of course he realized that if he did
this he would be prosecuted immediately
and most likely found guilty and forced
to relinquish his military command and
political future
therefore on january 10 49 bc caesar did
something that forever changed the
course of roman history
he crossed the rubicon nowadays crossing
the rubicon as an expression meaning to
pass the point of no return but back
then it was literal
the rubicon was the river that separated
italy proper from the province of
cesalpine gaul to the north crossing it
with an army was forbidden as it was
considered an attempted coup so
as soon as he did this caesar became an
enemy of the state and plunged rome into
civil war by this point brutus was
firmly on the side of pompei regardless
of his feelings towards his father's
killer
surely he was helped by the fact that
his uncle carto whom he respected
greatly was one of caesar's fiercest
opponents
at first he was sent away from the
danger to cilicio where he was to serve
as legates to cestia as the new governor
but brutus wanted to be in the middle of
the fight so he went back and joined
pompey's army according to plutarch when
he saw brutus arrive pompe was so filled
with delight and admiration
that he rose up and went to embrace him
in front of his retinue and he was not
the only one who displayed a fondness
for brutus caesar also instructed his
troops not to harm him and to take him
prisoner and to even leave him alone if
he resisted
so why the preferential treatments well
there is some quality scuttlebutt
provided to us once again by plutaku
claimed that in his youth caesar had an
affair with sevilla brutus's mother and
that caesar had reason to suspect that
he might have been brutus's real father
technically caesar's civil war lasted
for five years but most of that time was
spent settling matters in africa and
tracing down the last remaining
opponents in reality the outcome had
been decided after only a year and a
half following caesar's decisive victory
at the battle of fasalas which
resulted in pompei fleeing to egypt and
being assassinated as soon as he got
there
as far as brutus was concerned he took
part in that battle but managed to
escape unscathed and
without being taken prisoner he made his
way to larissa
where he realized that the war was lost
even before knowing that pompeii was
dead
some of his allies kept fighting his
uncle carto for example refused to
concede defeat and
retreated to africa with his remaining
troops it wasn't until 46 bc that he was
finally bested at the battle of
thapsis and then he committed suicide
soon after
brutus did not go to the same extreme
lengths as his uncle instead he wrote to
caesar and asked for his forgiveness
which was immediately forthcoming this
led credence to the rumor that the two
were actually father and son
as did the fact that caesar not only
forgave him but accepted brutus into his
inner circle and began bestowing upon
him multiple honours and titles
even though the two had been enemies
just a few months prior first brutus was
made a pontifex which
is a senior priest then in 47 bc he was
appointed as the new governor of cesar
pine gaul in 44 bc caesar made him a
prey tour with the promise that he would
become a consul in just a few more years
brutus was climbing the ranks of rome's
political world at an incredible pace
but
in his heart he was still a devoted
republican when he admitted defeat and
accepted caesar's favor he did so in the
belief that eventually
things would go back to how they were
before but it became increasingly clear
that this would not be the case
initially after his triumph at pasala
caesar went to rome and
declared himself a dictator for ten
years this was something that brutus and
his ilk could stomach not
that they had much choice in the matter
though it basically meant
that caesar was setting himself up to
become the most powerful statesman in
rome and would get away with everything
he'd ever done
without being punished this was to be
expected but then caesar shocked
everyone in january 44 bc when he
proclaimed himself
dictator perpetuo making himself a
dictator for life
this likely meant the end of the roman
republic unless new action was taken
even though it would probably have
benefited brutus to stay loyal to caesar
he placed his ideals and his family's
legacy as tyrant slayers
over his own well-being and well a new
conspiracy was born
[Music]
brutus became one of the leading figures
in a plot to assassinate caesar and
restore the republic to its former glory
other notable members included a distant
cousin of his decimus brutus who
actually sided with caesar during the
civil war and gaius cassius a
senator who fought against caesar but
just like brutus was forgiven and
provided with a prominent position back
in rome it has been said that cassius
was the main
instigator of the conspiracy but
ultimately brutus became
the figurehead of the group due to his
influence his position
and his family's renown together they
turned dozens of senators against caesar
as a lot of them felt that
it was only a matter of time before the
dictator tried to appoint himself the
new king of rome
they obviously did not need this many
men to kill caesar but rather
in order to show the people that the
killing was justified they understood
that caesar was popular with the
plebeians and his death might not be
seen as a good thing by the romans
the liberators as they called themselves
were hoping that if enough of rome's
leading men were recruited to their side
the people would see them as the senate
rising up to slay a tyrant
and saving the republic the liberators
knew that they were walking on thin ice
and they disagreed over how far they
should go the most extremist among them
wanted things to go back to how they
once were for this they intended to kill
caesar and all of his political
supporters and to dismiss all the new
policies and reforms introduced by the
dictator some of caesar's former allies
thought this was too extreme they wanted
to keep the reforms and to only slay
caesar himself
and mark anthony who was his strongest
supporter brutus was even more lenient
than this
and he was steadfast that only caesar
himself should die
if they were to portray themselves as
deliverers of justice anything more than
that would have looked like a purge of
the people who disagreed with them
which likely would have resulted in a
riot or even a new civil war
afterwards they also bickered over the
location of the attack a dark alley at
night would have been a safer spot
but it made them look like common
murderers it was decided that the deed
should be done inside the senate house
itself for two reasons
one the symbolism and two because only
senators were allowed inside so caesar
would not have his usual retinue with
him the assassination took place on the
ides of march a notable day in the roman
calendar that fell on march
15th caesar was getting ready to leave
rome to embark upon a military campaign
against the parthian empire according to
suetonius the dictator had been warned
of danger by a seer named spirina but
where the ides of march
was the soothsayer's famous line
although it too came from shakespeare
not any historical account the night
before caesar's wife had
also had a nightmare involving his death
and begged hers but not to go to the
senate house on that day
at first he acquiesced to her request
and stayed home but it was decimus
brutus who
came to his house and convinced him that
someone of his status should not pay
attention to the dreams of women
and foolish men caesar relented and
later that day he entered the senate
house
here's what happened according to
cassius dio and when the right moment
came one of them approached him as if to
express his thanks for some favor or
other
and pulled his toga from his shoulder
thus giving the signal that had been
agreed upon by the conspirators
thereupon they attacked him from many
sides at once and wounded him to death
so
that by reason of their numbers caesar
was unable to say or do anything but
veiling his face was slain with many
wounds
suetonius gives roughly the same account
although he names casker as the man who
struck the first blow and he specifies
that caesar was stabbed 23 times
as brutus approached to deliver his blow
julius caesar looked up at him and said
you too my child a famous phrase was
also credited to brutus who allegedly
screamed out sic
semper tyranus thus always to tyrants
although there is no historical account
at this happening closest we get is
plutarch who claimed that brutus went to
the middle of the room once caesar was
dead and tried to speak but
nobody heard him as all the senators
were screaming and running away
the phrase became famous once again 1900
years later when john wilkes booth
shouted it as he shot abraham lincoln
[Music]
liberatores killed julius caesar in the
hopes of saving the roman republic but
soon enough it became evident that
their actions would not have the desired
effect immediately after the
assassination the conspirators went to
the capitol where they flashed their
bloody daggers and
brutus gave an impassioned speech to
rally the people to their side
here among the senators officials and
other upperclassmen it worked but things
went differently when the conspirators
went down to the forum
among the common people as soon as
another conspirator named sinner tried
to denounce caesar the crowd turned on
them furiously
prompting brutus and his confederates to
retreat back to the capital
the following day they met marc anthony
caesar's formal ally
hoping that they could get him on their
side which would go a long way towards
earning the approval of the people
anthony agreed to their terms but made
two demands that caesar's will
be read in public and that he would be
given a proper funeral with honors
other conspirators such as cassius were
against such measures but brutus
accepted them looking back
this was his biggest mistake and one
that doomed him
and his cohorts during the funeral
anthony whipped the crowd into a frenzy
of support for caesar he showed them his
bloody robes pointing out all the holes
where
he was pierced with daggers he read the
will which awarded 75 drachmas to every
roman and
left caesar's private gardens to the
people he left no more room for doubt
the people of rome
loved caesar and they wanted to punish
his murderers brutus and cassius fled
the city and
traveled to the eastern provinces where
they controlled the armies meanwhile
back in rome mark antony had allied
himself with octavian caesar's heir and
marcus lepidus caesar's former master of
the horse to form the second triumvirate
with the goal of avenging his
assassination this became known as the
liberator civil war brutus and cassius
set up their headquarters in macedonia
his cousin desmus brutus tried to make
his way out to them but he was killed on
route by a gaelic chieftain loyal to
anthony once the battle lines had been
drawn the two sides met in combat twice
both near the greek city of philippi the
first encounter took place on october
3rd 42 bc and ended without a conclusive
winner brutus and his forces
fought octavian he managed to push back
his enemy and capture his camp meanwhile
marc anthony fought cassius and did the
same thing
eventually anthony retreated to help
octavian but not before cassius thought
the battle was lost and committed
suicide both sides retreated with brutus
now in charge of the entire liberator
army the second battle of philippi took
place on october 23rd and this one ended
with a decisive victory for the second
triumvirate brutus managed to escape
into the nearby hills with a small part
of his army but he knew that the war was
lost
later that night after having a last few
conversations in camp with his
companions brutus rose up and said
by all means must we fly not with our
feet however
but with our hands afterwards he
withdrew with only a few close friends
and committed suicide by impaling
himself on his sword when marc anthony
found his dead body he showed him
respect by wrapping him in his own robes
and giving him a funeral with honors and
then
sending his ashes to his mother sevilla
brutus was dead and with him died any
hope of the roman republic ever going
back to what it used to be but the
collapse of the republic made way for
bigger things
afterwards the second chamber was in
charge of rome and they soon turned
against each other and fought for
supremacy octavian came out on top
became augustus caesar and started the
roman empire showing brutus and his
followers that
what they thought would be the end of
rome was actually the beginning
of its greatest era so i really hope you
enjoyed this video thank you again to
magic spoon for sponsoring it please do
check them out there's a link below
and thank you for watching
you